this video is sponsored by skillshare
warning if you are watching this video
that means you're books every now and
then I like to talk about a book series
that I love that not many people maybe
know about even though the channel has
just become an extended meme
uh today I want to talk about a writer
who I have come to a door through
multiple series a hugely prolific writer
named Lawrence block he's written over a
hundred novels truly a master of his
craft he was a contemporary of Donald
Westlake and they were actually friends
Donald West like I talked about being
the writer of the Parker series today I
want to talk about the Scudder series
Matthew Scudder they're a detective
series I think there are 16 books in the
series they were begun in the 70s and
they they haven't ended because Lawrence
block is still alive in writing but we
don't know if there will be any more but
before I get to my next point I do want
to talk about skillshare skillshare is
an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
creators explore new skills deepen
existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skillshare skillshare
has been my longest and most consistent
sponsorship I'm very grateful and very
happy to be working with them I love
using skillshare and I just want to
recommend a couple classes that I have
enjoyed that I think you may enjoy I've
recommend this before I'll recommend it
again the writer's toolkit six steps to
a successful riding habit by Simon van
Bowie I mean setting up your writing
routine is like super important and
figuring out what works for you you can
have more of a strict type of schedule
or a loose schedule I mean it's the
process is so subjective like I don't
you know so this I thought was a very
useful series and I really enjoyed
watching it also Nathaniel drew a
YouTuber I really like
um has a skillshare original it is
called document your life for methods to
live more intentionally very informed
and had a great polish it was really fun
to watch so do check that out you can do
it in bite size videos or watch the full
course it's curated specifically for
learning meaning there are no ads
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused
skillshare now offers classes in Spanish
French Portuguese and Germany you may
know skillshare for classes in
photography film and video editing and
illustration but did you know that
skillshare has hundreds of career
focused classes too New Year's the
perfect time to reinvent your goals and
yourself traditional work and jobs are
not one size fits all learn how to
design a career to fit you first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description get skillshare for free
for one month what are you waiting for
go just click on it and enjoy learn
something new thank you skillshare now
back to the stuff Lawrence block was in
a generation of like crime fiction
writers who started out in pulps just
writing whatever he started out writing
erotic fiction so did Donald Lee
Westlake and they wrote Under many
pseudonyms basically the erotic fiction
that they wrote back then compared to
now would be like nothing like I'm sure
HBO or like the regular HBO show has
things way more explicit than what was
in these erotic books but that's where
they got their start and Lawrence block
always intrigued me and I was really
drawn to people like Lawrence block and
Donald Westlake for their ability to
move between genres to just to write
prolifically and at an extremely good
craft level blending crime and humor
Donald D Westlake had his comic
dortmunders series along with all his
other comic crime novels but he also
wrote as Richard Stark the Parker series
which is like the hardest of hard-boiled
uh Noir fiction go check out my video on
Parker if you haven't seen it yet
Lawrence block kind of had that same
thing it seemed to me he had Bernie
rodenbar let me see yeah he did the
burglar series
um which are sort of like light fun
novels I think this is a sign oh yeah
this is signed just bragging I guess but
what I loved about Lawrence block was
this ability to change voices and write
in such different tones and styles and
be able to move between those I think to
me that shows like a mastering of The
Craft there is artistry there but like
to to do it at that level you have to be
insanely good amazing to see and you
start to see patterns in their work I
love like super prolific writers you can
pick and choose what you like and not
everything's great but you you find you
gravitate towards certain things at
first I gravitated towards a character
called called Keller uh the Keller
series which is about a Hitman I would
say that the show Barry was heavily
influenced by Keller I've talked about
this series a lot mostly short stories
collected into collections the first one
is called Hitman and it's great you
should read those very dry humor so I
recommended those and that was like
going through Reading some short stories
by the way there's one Lawrence block
short story that I highly recommend I
believe it's called going through the
motions dark uh kind of Twisted story
when talking about Lawrence block
everyone would say yeah Bernie rodenbar
is great Keller's great all his other
you know Standalone books are great but
the real series the real good stuff is
the Scudder series Matthew Scudder these
are first person stories about an ex-cop
who does detective work in New York City
and to me I went that sounds really
Bland and boring and they're serious and
they're dark they largely involve his
alcoholism a character study basically
over a bunch of mysteries that you know
span a bunch of years I didn't find this
very interesting I thought well you know
I've seen the sad detective is obsessive
and Moody and whatever so I was like I
don't know I've seen this before but you
have to remember like I'm sure this was
a very important development in like the
crime fiction genre in my mind when you
look at like American Crime fiction it
starts with Hamot who was a private
detective himself before writing and
then it moves on to Chandler who had his
own stylistic stuff going on and it
moves on to like Ross McDonald and John
D McDonald the McDonald's I think that
Lawrence block was a huge and the
Scudder series was a huge huge in
developing what was the private eye
character Scudder isn't technically a
private eye but he functions that way he
takes favors you know he doesn't need to
worry about taxes I guess he kind of has
an addiction to solving crime he's
chosen to isolate himself but when I
dove into like the first book just
reading that first chapter it's kind of
electrifying how good that first chapter
is and how it pulls you into this
character and makes you feel immediately
like this there may be a mystery going
on but it's really about this narrator
and the narrators going to reveal
himself in very Sly ways very indirect
ways because this is a very suppressed
person Scudder is very suppressed he's
holding back a lot of pain and a lot of
darkness and we get to see that play out
in how he solves these cases and how he
goes about his with his drinking it's
never super direct and it it's very slow
to reveal itself but and there are like
multi-novel character arcs going like
character are going on for Scudder so
who is Matthew Scudder and what makes
him different from any other private
detective series you're going to read so
the series starts in the 70s the mid 70s
very of its time in a lot of ways not
super you know let's just say that the
times have changed for good reason so
they are gritty and there's very dated
stuff going on as what you'd expect in
any crime story from the 70s Scudder was
a cop who accidentally killed old a
little girl one of his bullets
ricocheted and it was just a random
thing you know like she was way out of
range but she he just she just happened
to get hit so he he took that very hard
he got divorced moved into the City and
is living this isolated life in a hotel
room solving cases doing private
detective work for people who get
recommended to him by his old friends or
whatever but he's basically just roaming
around solving cases and dealing with
his alcoholism and early in the books
it's not even discussed as an issue it's
just like he drinks he has his whiskey
he has his coffee he gets through the
day he drinks every scene it's constant
it's amazing how you can have these
self-contained stories but over the and
very entertaining like I'm not saying
the the Mysteries are are exceptional
they're good especially the early ones
they're very good time to murder and
create I think has a fantastic mystery
so they're engaging in that way but the
deeper thing is how does this all affect
Scudder how does he process what he's
seeing and how is he dealing with what's
going on he can admit to himself that
you know and there's one scene very
interesting early in the books where he
admits that you know I have a problem
and he's telling you know like someone
he's seeing he says you know I have I
drink you know it's currently not a huge
issue but it's probably going to be an
issue later on just based on what I know
about my patterns and behavior and
haven't completed this series it's a
long series I don't want to complete it
super fast I've kind of been tearing
through the books this year I just
completed the fifth book eight million
ways to die and I I don't think Lawrence
block was going to write more books
after that he just kind of got sucked
into it again and figured out a new ways
to write about this character more but
it really goes through this Arc where
he's learning to accept what actually
happened and how to deal with it in a
healthy way and eight million ways to
die is absolutely the best book in the
series that I've read so far are it has
a great mystery with some great
characters but it is it's longer and it
has way more there to say about Scudder
and about New York City and about
dealing with
trauma dealing with the past Scudder is
actively trying you know he's actively
going to AAA meetings and we have the
mystery we have the AAA meetings and
it's they're both are competing for our
attention because both are so
interesting and kind of heartbreaking
and it's frightening you know getting to
see a Scudder go through you know this
character who's so reliable and
dependable who do we rely on to saw and
he relies on himself you know to be
self-sufficient he's so isolated and
self-sufficient and that for him to
finally be able to say I need help you
know I can't do this alone it's really
just remarkable and you know you get to
you know this is you wouldn't expect
this in like these crime stories that by
the end of this book eight million ways
to die it's like you want to cry for
this character it's so sad but moving
it's just such a wonderful and like
subtle portrait of this sad person if
you're not naturally drawn to like crime
stories or Mysteries because you want
more character focused I'd say Scutter
is the way to go however the first three
books are kind of not essential like
like they are good to read but I do
think that they started out as just like
self-contained mystery stories they're
super quick reads like time to murder
and create I think this is the second
one this has a great story a great
mystery that's about there's a
blackmailer who is friends with Scudder
who tells him like Hey if someone kills
me there are three people who have been
blackmailing one of them would have done
it so if I die please figure out who did
it and then release this blackmail on
them for killing me it's like his
insurance you know Scudder is his
insurance so it's it's great you know
he's basically putting a Target on his
back to be like okay I'm going to go
pressure these people who have been
blackmailed by this other guy who just
got killed and whoever tries to kill me
you know I'll just that's probably who
the who the Killer is you know so um he
kind of has a lack of regard for his own
safety and well-being less than 200
Pages really Snappy read the pros is
it's borderline invisible and I know
there's there's no invisible prose but
it is so like it shows who his character
is but it is extremely simple but that
is who Scudder is it's so direct and
hiding so much underneath the simple the
Simplicity it's it's hiding a lot of
complexity for the next three days I
read the papers twice a day and waited
for a phone call Monday night I picked
up the early edition of the times on the
way to my room under the heading of
Metropolitan briefs there's always a
batch of crime items tagged from the
police blotter and the last one was the
one I was looking for an unidentified
male white height approximately five six
weighed approximately 140 age
approximately 45 had been fished out of
the East River with a crushed skull the
first book is called the sins of the
fathers great mystery there is a woman
killed we know who the Killer is we
think we know who the Killer is but the
father comes to Scudder because he wants
to know who his daughter was before she
was killed she was you know estranged
from the family Etc so a great mystery
unfolds a lot of Dark Secrets family
traumas Etc I will say one big Mark
against the sins of the fathers because
it's a fantastic mystery my one problem
is that the conclusion is so like 70s
pop psychology like Freudian
nightmare like very dated very clumsy
like an explanation that's satisfying
but like the deeper like psychological
stuff I'm glad that got abandoned in the
later books because scudder's kind of
doing some pop psychology on this guy
I'm like can we no no no no just don't
even go there this is not this is weird
so that's the sins of the fathers then
we have time to murder and create which
is about the blackmailer I told told you
about that in the midst of death is
about a Cop turned informant who's
trying to root out the corruption going
on the police force very interesting
details about you know corruption New
York City cops scutters relationship to
that but it appears like he's being
framed for the murder of a prostitute so
Scudder is
trying to solve that crime the fourth
book is called a stab in the dark and
this is definitely the second best next
to eight million ways to die of the
first five that I've read a stab in the
dark is about a there's a murder that
was supposedly done by a serial killer
but turns out to have been impossible
once the serial Killer's identity was
found years later this is a murder that
occurred nine years ago the cops don't
care about investigating this crime
anymore it was nine years ago but the
father of the daughter comes to Scudder
and wants him to investigate it and find
out who the real killer is it's called a
stab in the dark because the whole
thing's like chances of solving this
crime are so are it's so impossible you
know but Scudder does it anyway partly
because he's really struggling with his
his drinking and this is the one where
the problems around his drinking are
really coming to light it's becoming
very clear we get some characters that
will stick around for some of the books
so I'm if you just care about the more
deeper psychology if you don't really
want to have those introductory three
books the great books the first three
but I really think books four and five
are of a are a great pair to see like
the best of the early part of this
series a stab in the dark is fantastic
and then of course we get eight million
ways to die a book that is so fantastic
and amazing like I I was talking mostly
about the stuff with Scudder going to
AAA meetings I didn't even mention the
excellent stuff going on there are these
women getting killed these prostitutes
and the weird interesting Dynamics with
chance who is their pimp and the weird
relationship chance and Scudder have
really interesting Dynamics really great
the mystery is good for sure but the
book is really about like Scudder
himself stab in the dark eight million
ways to die 8 million ways to die was
turned into a film in the 80s I think
directed by Hal Ashby of all people and
you know Scudder is the whole series is
about New York City City and hey let's
set this adaptation in La I have not
seen this movie full disclosure but the
clips I have seen of the movie I cannot
even see where it's from the book like
the book is so different I don't even
know how they adapted that from the same
Source material I have no idea but
speaking of movie adaptations we have 8
million ways to die very famous it was a
huge disaster like box office wise and
was cut up by the studio and anyways
that's a whole interesting thing you can
dive into of that movie production
another one is more recent Liam Neeson
played Scudder in A Walk Among the
Tombstones I have not seen that movie
yet because I have not read the book yet
here's a beautiful edition of that book
A Walk Among the Tombstones if you want
to watch a Scudder movie I guess there's
that I can't attest to its quality
here's another nice addition I have of a
dance at the slaughterhouse anyways um I
cannot recommend these books enough I
really think that if you like crime
fiction if you want to read some older
detective stuff that's also feels modern
check out the Matthew Scudder Series
start with the sins of the fathers start
with a stab in the dark you know
whatever if you want a different type of
Lawrence read a short stories I mean
there's so much to explore if you like
this kind of uh Noir if you like um yeah
I mean it's it's just great I cannot
recommend Lawrence block enough also
great uh writing books actually Lawrence
block has written writing handbooks and
stuff like that so I hope this was
entertaining somehow uh thank you so
much for watching thank you again
skillshare for sponsoring this video and
I hope you all have a lovely day bye bye
good